BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
Thanks for coming!
Obviously, this is a
very special thing for me
as well, because this is my
husband, Christian Picciolini.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
For those of you who I haven't
met, I am Britton Picciolini.
I've been here in
the Google Chicago
office for almost 13 years.
It's 13 in June.
So it's really exciting for
me to have Christian here
because he's grown
up with Google
and I've grown up with him
in the last 15 years or so.
So just to start,
I'm going to play
a quick video that was part
of his Kickstarter efforts,
just the first couple minutes.
It gives a little context on
Christian's life up until now.
So I'm just going to play that.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: My
name's Christian Picciolini,
and I'm a 40 year-old
husband and a father of two.
I grew up in a small, south side
Italian neighborhood of Chicago
called Blue Island.
I was a good kid from a
hardworking, Italian immigrant
family until one day.
I met the most dangerous man in
America and everything changed.
[MUSIC SKREWDRIVER, "WHITE
POWER"]
From the time I was
14 years-old in 1987
until I hit bottom
in 1995, I was
one of the leaders of America's
most violent neo-Nazi hate
groups.
The white race suffers
from the rest of the world,
and it [INAUDIBLE] a lot.
In America, the racial
tension's boiling over.
Thankfully, a lot's
changed since then.
Now I lead a different
group of pioneers.
I co-founded a
nonprofit organization
called Life After
Hate in 2010 that's
made up of former
racist skinheads who
have dedicated their
lives to combating hate
through peaceful means.
For two decades, I've
searched my own soul,
wondering how I could have
strayed so far off track,
committed vile acts of
hatred, and advocated
for the annihilation
of someone based solely
on the color of their
skin, who they loved,
or the gods to
which they prayed.
In 2008, 13 years after I
left the American white power
movement that I'd helped found,
I started to document my story,
hoping that others would
read it and realize
how disturbingly easy it is to
enter a world full of prejudice
and violence.
"Romantic Violence" is fully
written, but I need your--
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: All right.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK.
This is my dream job.
I get to grill my husband.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
That's not the deal.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
OK, by way of intro,
let's just run through this.
Are we still good on volume?
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: Yes.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: Right.
Christian Picciolini is an
award-winning television
producer, visual artists,
and reformed extremist.
After leaving the
violent hate movement
he was part of
during his youth, he
began a painstaking process
of rebuilding his life.
Picciolini earned a degree
in international business
and international relations
from DePaul University,
began his own global
entertainment and media firm,
and was appointed a member
of the Chicago Grammy
Rockies [INAUDIBLE].
In 2010 and 2011,
he was nominated
for three regional Emmy
awards for his role
as executive
producer of JBTV, one
of America's longest running
national broadcast music
television programs.
He's worked as an adjunct
professor at the college level
as the community partnerships
manager for Threadless.
Additionally, in
2013, he contributed
to Google Chairman Eric
Schmidt's and Director
of Google Ideas Jared Cohen's
New York Times bestseller
"The New Digital Age."
Most notably, in 2010, he
co-founded Life After Hate,
a nonprofit
organization dedicated
to helping communities
and organizations gain
the knowledge necessary
to implement long term
solutions that counter
all types of racism
and violent extremism.
Please help me
welcome Christian.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Thank you.
I remember coming
to Google when there
were this many people working
in the Chicago office total.
It was pretty cool.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: Less.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
Yeah, less.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: Less.
So why write the book?
Could have kept it private.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Yeah.
It's taken me 10 years
to write the book.
Why write the book?
So after I left the
movement in '95,
I went through a
pretty dark depression.
It was a really dark
period of my life
until '99 when I started
working a temp job for IBM.
A friend of mine recognized
I was going through a pretty
dark depression, and she
may be apply for a job
that I had absolutely no skills
for, I wasn't qualified for,
but I decided I was gonna
fake it until I made it.
I got the job with
IBM, and the first out
of all the millions of places
that big blue could have put me
for a job, the one place that
they placed me for my first job
was the high school that I'd
gotten kicked out of twice.
And I was terrified.
I thought for sure somebody's
going to see me in the hallway,
an old teacher, an old
principal, whatever.
And they're going to rat me out.
They're going to tell my boss.
I'm going to get fired.
Here I've got this somewhat
of a decent temp job,
and I'm just going
to get called out.
And my second day at my high
school for this computer
rollout that we were doing,
I saw an old security guard
that I'd gotten in
a fistfight with.
And I don't know why.
I decided to run after him.
And I tapped him
on the shoulder,
and I said Mr. Holmes,
I'm Christian Picciolini.
I don't know if you remember me.
And he stopped me right away.
And his just dropped
as he turned around.
And he said, oh
yeah, I remember you.
And right then and there,
I said, Mr. Holmes, I just
want you to know that
I'm not that person.
And I told him my story.
And he shook my hand and
this redemptive light
encapsulated us and I started
to cry and he started to cry.
And he made me promise that I
would tell the world my story.
So that was one
of the catalysts.
I'd gone through this
period where I really didn't
want to talk about my past.
I thought if I
didn't talk about it
and I just worked
down a different path
that it would never
come back to me.
But I, internally,
wasn't healing.
I wasn't living a positive life.
So when I saw Mr. Holmes
the security guard,
and he urged me to tell
the world, it clicked.
I knew that at that moment
that, in order for me to heal,
I really needed to tell
the world about what
I went through.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: Well, let's
actually hear from the book.
So you want to read the
first full chapter, correct?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Yeah,
the book is actually out today.
Today is the first
day that it's out.
And I want to read the
first chapter, which
goes back to 8th grade.
For me, it was a
significant moment
because it really introduced me
to violence for the first time
and the power of it.
I was a pretty
innocent, normal kid.
My parents were
Italian immigrants
who came to this country in the
'60s, and I was pretty lonely.
They had moved to an Italian
neighborhood on the southwest
side of Chicago
called Blue Island,
what you saw in the video.
And my parents were seeking
this slice of the American pie.
So they went and they worked.
And they started
their own business,
and I rarely saw them.
So I was raised while they
were at work by my grandparents
and my aunts and
uncles in Blue Island.
But they moved me
to Oak Forest, which
was a middle class,
upper-middle class neighborhood
at the time to school there.
So if you can envision
this, Monday through Friday,
I would go to school
at this Catholic school
with a bunch of white kids,
privileged white kids.
And I was picked up
every day at 3 o'clock
and shipped back to Blue Island
with all the Italian kids.
So I never really
got an opportunity
to make friends in Oak Forest
because I didn't hang out
after school.
And I never made friends
with anybody in Blue Island
because I didn't really
go to school with them.
Kids are cruel, so--
I'm going to read
the first chapter
book that sets everything up.
Jake Reilly picked be randomly
that soggy, April afternoon
to be the target of his
malicious playground taunts,
insulting me for anything
he could think of.
He was the quintessential
class bully, Goliath,
as we had secretly referred
to him since the 1st grade.
And he took great pleasure
in routinely tormenting
his less fortunate eighth
grade classmates at St. Damian
Elementary School.
Today, for what seemed the
millionth time, he chose me.
Fuck you, I fired off.
I instantly wished I could take
back my words as I spun around
straight into the puffed
out chest of the grinning
Goliath, who I realized
had just rifled
a handful of frozen grapes
at the back of my head.
Fuck me.
The whispering chatterboxes,
and plaid smocks and pig tails,
and the skinny
jungle gym rats who
were gathered around
various puddle
clusters on the playground
wasted no time sensing
the fresh blood in the water.
Like hungry sharks smelling
chum, they closed in around us
in a flash.
Oh look.
Isn't it Pick-My-Weenie
tough, Jake
snickered while jabbing
me hard in the chest
with his chubby index finger.
He loved to mangle
my foreign last name
and never ran out of
creative ways to do so.
How I longed for a normal name
like Eddie Peterson, Dan Cook,
or Jimmy Mayfair.
Anything but the impossible
to say Christian Picciolini,
pronounced Pee-cho-lee-nee,
which made for all kinds of God
awful rhyming nicknames--
Pick-my-weenie, Suck-my-weenie,
Lick-my-weenie--
basically anything Weenie.
You gonna sic your greasy Blue
Island dago friends on me,
he mocked, making fun of the
largely Italian neighborhood
just outside of Chicago,
where my parents had moved us
from before landing in the
suburban hellhole of Oak
Forest, Illinois.
After school, cheesedick, I'm
kicking your slimy Italian ass
back to the ghetto
where you belong.
Jake didn't flinch at
calling another student
an assface or a dick with ears
whenever her felt like it.
And he never lied about
delivering a beating.
But no one had ever dared
challenge him with a fuck you
before.
Even if it had escaped my
mouth by regrettable accident,
I was a dead man and
everybody knew it.
Certainly was nice of him to
suggest I had friends though.
And if you don't show
up again this time,
pussy, he sneered, reeling me
in close by my hood strings,
I'll fucking kill you.
Throughout eight years
of elementary school,
I'd managed to
invent enough excuses
to avoid getting physically
rearranged by Jake.
But before I could muster a lie
good enough for me to skip out
on this particular jam, word
spread faster than Nutella
on warm toast.
And by the time the
final recess bell rang,
everybody knew about the
fight, except for the adults,
of course.
They were never there
when you needed them.
I prayed one of the
teachers or the principal
herself would catch wind of the
fight and put and end to it.
But my prayers went unanswered.
Doom loomed over me.
Jake Reilly was much bigger,
thick, and tall, and strong,
and he'd surely have
his cronies behind him.
I'd be in it alone.
I didn't have any
friends in Oak Forest,
or even Blue Island for
that matter, to back me up.
Other than a few
moves I picked up
when I watched "Rocky"
beat up Mr. T in the movies
or how "Rowdy"
Roddy Piper smashed
Hulk Hogan over the head with
a steel chair on TV wrestling,
I had no clue how to
fight or defend myself.
But I couldn't back
down now, not this time,
not with four years of
Goliath-dominated high school
and an endless supply of
ridicule on the horizon.
Running away and being
forever branded a pussy
would be infinitely worse
than getting pummeled.
Hoping that with
more time, I might
be able to come up with a
believable last minute excuse
to not show up and
get my ass kicked,
I took the longer route
home after the final class
bell rang.
No such luck.
All I could think about was
how to convince my parents
to let me transfer
schools by tomorrow
so I wouldn't have to
deal with the mockery that
was sure to be heaped on me by
my classmates the next morning.
My parents weren't home.
I changed out of my light blue
school uniform and navy slacks,
grabbed my Santa Cruz skateboard
and apprehensively rode
the six blocks to the park
where the fight was to happen.
I knew the entire 8th
grade class would be there
to witness my slaughter.
People even placed
bets and proclaimed
the loser, who everybody
full expected to be me,
would have to pay
the winner 10 bucks.
The moment the
fight was over, I'd
be ruined forever, beaten,
stigmatized, and forgotten,
cast atop the growing heap
of junior high nobodies who'd
already been
humiliated by Goliath.
I couldn't care
less about where I'd
get the money to pay
off to the stupid bet,
knowing I could easily swipe
that from my grandmother's
purse without her knowledge.
But I also knew that once I was
dispatched into nothingness,
there was no coming back.
No one ever recovered from that.
As I rode up, I spied the
giant lumbering confidently
among the large group
that had gathered
like buzzards anticipating
a fresh roadkill buffet.
Attempting to steady
my shaking knees,
trying to keep my
fear under wraps,
I stepped off my
board, struggled
to take in my
finals gulps of air.
Wiping away the nervous sweat
that was already trickling down
my brow, I thought one last
time about running away.
Maybe being exiled
from the ranks of St.
Damian's lower order
wouldn't be worse
than getting my face pounded
in by this massive beast.
As I retreated backwards,
planting my foot back
onto my skateboard,
and turning to push off
with my unsteady leg, some of
the more spiteful onlookers
suddenly broke into a clamor.
Pick my weenie, pick my
weenie, pick my weenie!
Sensing my dread, the whole
crowd had turned against me.
I felt myself becoming dizzy
and detaching from reality,
fading into the ether.
As I inhaled another
series of quick,
shallow breaths to
try to calm my nerves.
I turned toward my tormentor
to accept my fate, just
as a colossal was of
spit flew through the air
and landed with a wet, dewy
thwack dead on my cheek.
Hushed silence, except
for Jake, whose loud,
guttural snort only meant that
another loogie was imminent.
Anxious panic of
flushed through me.
And before I could wipe
his spit from my face,
another glob of
thick yellow phlegm
struck me in the chest
like a sniper's bullet,
and slowly dribbled down
my turquoise ocean Pacific
T-shirt.
What's wrong, dickbreath,
Reilly jeered,
pudgy arms crossed
over his chest.
Are you chicken?
Bawk, bawk.
The crowd formed
a wall around us.
Suck-My-Weenie ain't got
no balls, he proclaimed.
A shock of laughter broke
out from the enclosing group
of spectators.
Jesus Christ, this kid was big.
Goliath was growing twice as big
as he stood before me, while I
shrunk smaller and smaller.
This is suicide, I thought.
He took a step towards
me and spat a third time
at ground near my feet, as if to
mark the spot of my execution.
as the grip of the taunting
mob tightened around us,
we circled each other, the
requisite trash talk spewing
from the ogre's crooked smile.
Jake was name-calling.
I was stalling.
My swollen purple
eye from last week,
the one I'd gotten when three
black kids from Blue Island
jumped me and stole my bike,
was finally beginning to heal.
And i didn't want
to have to explain
a fresh one to my parents.
Terror overtook me
and I could barely
hear the crowds
increasingly muffled chants
over my own fearful thoughts
and the dull, echoing crackle
of crisp leaves under my feet.
Quit being a faggot like
your pussy hairdresser dad,
and stand still so I
can frickin' kill you.
Jake made a beeline towards me.
The tendons in my arms
tightened, pulsed.
My mind spun with fear,
becoming further detached
from my surroundings.
My heart thumped out of chest.
Out of sheer despair, I summoned
the nerve to step in with him
and throw the first
punch-- kill or be killed.
What more could I lose?
At least I go to
my death valiantly.
My baby brother
buddy would be proud
that I wasn't a complete coward.
I shut my eyes and tensed
my sweaty right hand,
pulled it back, and swung
wildly, landing squarely.
Jake went down.
Holy shit.
My first instinct was
to bolt, but my legs
weren't cooperating.
From a sudden jumble of
gasps and groans behind me,
I made out the frenzied
voice of Jake's goon,
Kyle McKinney, yelling,
hit him, hit him!
But Jake stayed put on the
ground, confused, whimpering,
covering his bleeding nose.
Hit him again, his pal shouted.
Shocked, I realized
he actually wanted
me to beat up his best friend.
Could it be?
Was everyone as sick of
Goliath's bullying as I was?
Or was it that the
rush of fighting
was so intoxicating even
his most loyal subjects
savored the blood and violence
over their friendship?
I shook the thought
out of my head
and fell hard on that
bastard Jake Reilly
with eight solid years of
Catholic school retribution
on my mind.
Adrenalin pumping, I pinned
him down with my knees,
pulled back my fists and slammed
them onto his face again,
and again, and again.
Sobbing, he cried,
stop, stop, I quit.
Just stop.
You win.
Steams of tears turned
into crimson rivers
flowing down his bruised cheeks.
I rose to my feet and wiped
my bloodied, swollen knuckles
across my T-shirt.
You owe me 10 bucks,
was all I could
mutter through a mouth that
was absent of any saliva.
I turned to leave, though
my wobbly legs were barely
able to carry me, and I
thought I might pass out
right there in front of the
whole stunned 8th grade class.
Just then, my oxygen-deprived
lungs remembered to breath.
I inhaled deeply as the faint
sounds of hooting and hollering
slowly become audible
and then filled my ears.
The giant lay
defeated before me.
The next morning, my
classmates swarmed around me
the moment I got to school.
My once nonexistent stature
had grown to epic proportions
overnight.
I'd become a bully-slayer.
Even the cool kids who'd ignored
me for the last eight years
looked up to me because I'd
taken down one of their own.
Not to mention I
was 10 bucks richer.
I was drunk with my
new-found significance.
Suddenly, I wasn't
the weird Italian kid
who spent all his
after-school free time
with elderly grandparents
in their Blue Island
ghetto instead of the stale
upper-middle class confines
of this Oak Forest suburbia.
For a brief moment, I
wasn't the little boy
with the peculiar
mom and dad who
couldn't speak proper English,
who owned a beauty shop
and brought their kids sloppy
lunches in oil-stained paper
sacks.
No, I was the tough kid, the
most dangerous kid in school,
in all of Oak Forest, even.
And if Oak Forest had been
any closer than the 20 miles
away it was from
downtown Chicago,
then perhaps the mayor would
have even thrown a parade down
State Street in my honor.
During my first period
class, I flexed my fists,
silently studying them,
trying to take in the reality
that these two balled
up, bruised hands
were my ticket to
respect and power.
My baby brother
wouldn't be the only kid
that looked up to me anymore.
I took this lesson to
heart, absorbing it
in every fiber, every
muscle, and organ in my body.
It would end up serving me
well in the years to come,
when I'd help build one
of America's most violent
home terror organizations.
[APPLAUSE]
That was the moment
where I lost my innocence
and realized that power was
something that I wanted,
something that I wanted.
And the rest is kind of history.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: So let's
talk a little bit about music
and its relation to the story.
So as people have seen if
they've picked up the book,
Joan Jett did the
foreword for you.
There's a thread of music
throughout the entire book.
Do you want to talk a little bit
about how music played a role
in you becoming involved?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: So
right after that happened,
that was 8th grade
right before the summer
that I got recruited for
America's first white power
skinhead group so interestingly
enough, in the '60s-- skinheads
were born in the
'60s, and most people
associate being a skinhead with
being a neo-Nazi or a racist.
In fact, that's not true.
Racists and
nationalists co-opted
the skinhead subculture
And took it as their own.
So in the mid-80s,
'85, an individual
named Clark Martell took
this racist skinhead scene
from England and started the
first American white power
skinhead gang.
It just so happens that he
lived right across the alley
from where my friend
at the time lived.
And I remember the
first time I met
Clark Martell, I
was 14 years-old,
I was in an alley at night
with one of the few friends
that I had, smoking a
joint behind a garage.
And all of a sudden, we'd see
this car, this '69 Firebird,
just roaring down
this long alley.
It was like a scene out of a
film, and I'll never forget it.
And the car is spitting
up gravel and dust,
and it stops, screeching
like six inches
from where we were standing.
And I recognize the
car because it belonged
to the guy who lived
across the alley,
but I didn't
recognize the guy who
came out of the passenger side.
And as soon as the car stopped,
he made a beeline towards me.
And he came up to me took
the joint out of my mouth
and smacked me in the head hard.
And he said-- and I'll
never forget it-- don't you
know that that's what the
Communists and the Jews
want you to do to
keep you docile?
I was 14.
I didn't know what
a communist was.
I don't think I'd ever met
a Jewish person before,
and I certainly didn't know
what the word docile meant.
But I was struck
by his presence.
I was enamored by the
power that he had.
He was older.
He was 24 and I was 14.
But one thing I
recall was the music
that was playing
when the car stopped.
And I had been into punk
rock and the skater music
for a while.
And I recognized that it
was similar to punk rock,
but it was different.
And I actually
didn't remember this
until I did an interview
with someone last week.
When they asked me if there
was any other extremist
that had a soundtrack.
And I thought for a moment,
and I said I really don't know.
I think that skinheads might
be one of the only extremist
groups that actually have
music as a soundtrack.
They use music as
a recruiting tool.
And from the time
I was 14 years-old
until the time I was 25, music
played a really central role
in my part in the movement.
I was drawn in initially by
the music and by the fashion.
I didn't understand politics.
I wasn't raised to be racist.
Matter of fact, my
parents were often,
as immigrants, victims
of prejudice and racism.
But music drew me in.
It influenced me.
The lyrics that they
used in the songs
gave me the answers
to the problems that I
thought I had at the time.
I was lonely.
I was this disenfranchised
kid who really wanted
to do something that mattered.
I wanted to belong to something
because I was pretty lonely.
And music was the
tool that brought me
in to this subculture.
And in fact, it's probably the
most powerful propaganda tool
that racists in our
country, and even abroad,
have to recruit young people.
So it's a pretty powerful
tool that's used.
As far as Joan
Jett goes, in '96,
after I'd left
the movement, when
I was going through
that depression,
I started a punk band because
it was really the only thing
that I knew how to do.
I loved music.
I knew how to play
music, and I wanted
to do something that was
completely opposite of what
I had spent seven years doing.
And one of our first shows
happened by accident.
We were asked to open
a show for Joan Jett.
And of course, we said yes.
And during our soundcheck,
after our soundcheck,
Joan had noticed me backstage,
and I was depressed.
I was probably drunk.
And she came up to me
and put her arm around me
and said, hey.
Are you OK?
And I didnt know her.
I'd never met her before.
I was slightly starstruck by it.
And I started to
tell her my story.
I didn't mention that I was
involved in the movement,
but I had mentioned that I was
going through some tough times.
And she put her arm
around me, and she said
you guys were really great.
You guys should come
on tour with us.
And she didn't have to do that.
She didn't know me.
She didn't know
anything about my band.
She didn't know if we were
gonna sell tickets that night.
And it was one of
the first moments
after this depression
of not talking
about what I'd been
through that allowed
me to realize that there
were people out there that
cared about me.
So years later, we'd
done some touring.
She had managed us
for a little while.
Years later, when I
decided to finish the book,
I approached Joan and
I told her the story.
And I told her my
whole background.
And she was shocked.
She didn't know
anything about it,
but she agreed to
write the foreword,
and I think it's a
beautiful foreword.
I'm really glad that she did it.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: So you
talk about the movement.
You say the movement--
most people don't really
know much about the skinhead
culture and the movement.
I've learned a ton
from you, obviously,
just going through
this process with you.
But we don't hear a lot
about these domestic groups.
We hear a lot about ISIS.
We hear about ISIL.
We hear a lot about
what I would consider
international
non-domestic things.
We don't hear a lot about that,
and I think a lot of people
are surprised to hear
some of the facts
about some of the current
organizations in the United
States.
If you could talk a
little about that.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: In
the mid-80s til the mid-90s,
you could walk down
the streets of Chicago
and chances are pretty good you
would come across a skinhead
or somebody that looked like
a skinhead-- shaved head,
tattoos, boots.
Nowadays, you don't
see that as much.
Because one of
the things that we
taught when I was part
of the organization
was a concept called
leaderless resistance
and mainstreaming, which
taught people who were attached
to these groups to blend in,
So while you may
not see skinheads
throwing chairs on the
Geraldo Show or the Oprah Show
or whatever anymore,
they absolutely exist.
As a matter of fact,
the FBI just this year
released a report that
listed their top perceived
homegrown terrorist threats.
And of the 12 that were listed,
ISIS was not number one.
You would think because we
talk about it all the time.
They were number two.
Number one was a
group of white racists
called Sovereign Citizens.
Number three was
neo-Nazi skinheads.
Number four was Ku Klux Klan.
Number five was
Christian Identity.
What I'm trying to say is
all these groups put together
are what I was, just segmented.
So while we hear
a lot in the media
about middle class girls
going to Syria to join ISIS,
and that happens, I would
caution that there is probably
a bigger threat in this country
from far right extremists.
Though you may not see them,
I assure you they're there.
We see these things when a lone
wolf like Wade Michael Page
walks into a Sikh temple in Oak
Creek, Wisconsin and murderers,
tragically, seven
innocent people.
We hear it when
Randal Lee Krager
goes to a synagogue
parking lot in Missouri
and shoots who he thinks
are four Jewish people.
It happens all the time.
It doesn't happen
on a large scale.
It happens on an
individualized scale
and on a lone wolf basis, which
I think is much more dangerous.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: Why
doesn't the media seem
to put that angle out there?
I was shocked to
hear through you
that the Oklahoma
bombings were actually
related to the movement.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Yeah.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
It doesn't seem
like that was a
story at the time,
that that was a piece
of it, that it was just
a lone wolf and a
horrific bombing.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
Yeah, Timothy McVeigh
was found with a book called
"The Turner Diaries," which
was a book written-- a
fictional book that was written
about white extremists
blowing up a federal building
and causing widespread
chaos and murder.
And Timothy McVeigh was found
with copies of the book.
There was a copy of
the book in the van.
Why you don't hear about them?
I'm not really sure.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: Is
it lack of knowledge?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
No, I don't
think it's lack of knowledge.
I mean, media tends
to go with stories
that are a little bit more
exciting, and not exciting
in a positive way.
But the media focuses on
what's hot at the moment.
But lone wolf activities
happen all the time.
Every year, there's
dozens and dozens
of these tragedies that happen.
They don't point the finger
at them and I don't know why.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: You've
done quite a bit of consulting
with different law
enforcement organizations,
with the Anti-Defamation League.
Talk about what they look for
from you, from your experience.
What kind of things are they
trying to understand and gain
from you?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: So
like the video mentioned,
in 2010, I co-founded
an organization called
Life After Hate, which was set
up specifically to-- initially
it was set up for my partner
and I, when we found ourselves
after years of not knowing
what each other was doing,
he had left the movement
and had kids the same age.
I had left the movement
There was nowhere for us
to talk about our stories.
So we launched lifeafterhate.org
as a literary magazine,
an online magazine just
to talk about our stories.
Very quickly, we were
overwhelmed with people
reaching out from all over the
world who had similar stories.
Up until that time, there had
been no organization support
group for people
who left hate groups
or who wanted to leave
hate groups to get help.
And we quickly found out
that, through Life After Hate,
our unique perspective
was something
that law enforcement, and
academia, and community
organizations lacked.
They understood the problem.
They understood that
there was a problem,
but not having spent
time in those groups,
they didn't really
have a solution
to fix it from the inside out.
So when Life After Hate
became more of a consulting
organization, we started to
work with law enforcement
and with higher education
to help them understand
the mindset of how people are
recruited into these groups,
and likewise, what it
takes to deradicalize
people who are coming out
of these organizations.
Because, like myself, I
wasn't raised to be a racist.
It wasn't who I initially was.
I went through a
seven year period
where I was indoctrinated
and was passionate about what
I believed in.
But it wasn't my true self.
So like me, there are thousands
of other people out there
who went through that
and have never found out
how to integrate with
society in a positive way
after they've left these groups,
whether it's because they're
stigmatized or too scared to
talk about their experiences,
or whether they've gone
to prison or whatever.
It was our goal to really
help them understand
what it takes for people to
get introduced to these groups.
It's a common problem,
and we see it with ISIS.
We see it with other
extremist groups.
We see it with gangs.
There really isn't that much of
a difference between why people
join an inner-city street gang
and why they become a neo-Nazi
skinhead.
It's look for attention.
It's looking for
something to belong in.
It's trying to find an
excuse for the problems
that you're experiencing
in your life.
We never took responsibility
for our problems.
It was always because
of somebody else.
Black people would
move in, and that's
why there was more crime.
Or the Jews own the media.
That's why they
talk bad about us.
We never accepted the
responsibility ourselves
that our lives were
pretty shitty because we
made them pretty shitty.
So we really want to
help organizations
understand the mindset.
Because we think that that
could help solve the problem.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
One of the things
I was the most fascinated
by was to hear [INAUDIBLE]
this magic age of 14,
13, 14, that, I think,
a lot of you who came together
for a conference in Dublin
against discovered when
you were all telling
your story that there was a
common thread about a time
in your life that you
actually became indoctrinated
and part of the movement.
Can you talk about that?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
Yeah, that's
actually an interesting story.
And I ow a lot of the work that
Life After Hate does to Google.
Because in 2011,
Google Ideas sponsored
in Dublin, Ireland, a summit
against violent extremism.
It was the first
one of its kind,
and they invited about 150
former members of extremist
groups-- and that was everything
from far right extremism,
to former gang members,
to former IRA members,
to former Boko Haram, to you
name it-- but also invited
victims and survivors of
violence caused by extremists.
And they put us all
in the same room.
And it was Google Ideas and the
Council on Foreign Relations
and the Tribeca
Film Festival who
sponsored this event in Dublin.
And what we realized after
talking to each other,
this mind-bending experience
of being put in a room
and discussing what
we'd all been through,
that there's a pretty
common thread on why people
join these groups.
A lot of times it's young kids
around the ages of 12,13,14,
who are misguided and looking
for something to belong to,
moreso looking to do
something that matters.
I could have been intercepted
by ballerinas or whoever.
And I may have gone
down that path.
It just happens that a
charismatic individual
saw in me that I was
ambitious and looking
for something to belong to.
And it was a product of
environment and circumstance.
But I mean there's a
really common thread
on why young people
join extremist groups.
It's no different from
why they join gangs.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
Which is what?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: I think
you're looking for something
to belong to.
For me, specifically, I
was a pretty ambitious kid.
And when I saw this opportunity
to join a startup, which
is what the skinhead
movement was at the time,
I jumped at the opportunity.
There were these older guys who
were paying attention to me.
I was given tasks that mattered.
I would go to photocopy flyers,
and I would go put flyers
on their windshields.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
You were respected.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
I was respected
and I was rewarded
for my hard work
when everybody else
around me, like my family,
was too busy to notice that
I needed that attention.
So they paid attention to
me when I really needed it.
And not to say that there was
any lack of love or anything
in my life.
Because I was always
surrounded by love.
But I wasn't given
the attention that I
was looking for, which was to
do something that mattered.
So when they saw
that in me, they
scooped me up pretty quickly.
And it took me awhile to get
used to the politics of it.
At first, it wasn't
about the politics.
It was about the fashion and
being a part of this group.
But I quickly
became indoctrinated
into the politics, and I
was passionate about it.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
We're definitely
going to have time
for a few questions.
So think about what
you might want to ask.
The last question I'll
have for Christian
is a lot going on-- Baltimore,
pretty timely challenges
for the country right now.
What are your thoughts on things
like Ferguson and Baltimore.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
Well, I think it's tragic.
I mean, we see it over and over
again in places like Ferguson,
and New York, and Baltimore.
And I think that change has
to come from the community.
I think that community
leaders and faith leaders,
the power's in their
hands to fix the situation
in their communities.
I also think that there's a
problem with law enforcement.
I think that while
their job is to protect,
it is not so much
about serving anymore.
Not to say that they
don't have a tough job,
I think that law
enforcement is not
doing a good enough job
to understand what's
happening in the community.
I think the community's
not doing enough
to understand what's happening
at the law enforcement level.
But i think what
it boils down to is
that there's a
lack of opportunity
in a lot of these neighborhoods.
And with desperation, sometimes,
comes civil disobedience.
And for somebody who
doesn't have an option
to be heard, sometimes that
violence speaks the loudest.
Not to say that it's right, and
I certainly don't support it,
but I understand it.
And I think we have
a lot of work to do.
For me, one thing that
changed me was empathy.
I owned a record store in '95
when got out of the movement.
I had started the record
store because I wanted
to sell white power music.
I was doing it out
of my backpack.
And between getting laid
off from a construction job,
I wanted to be an
entrepreneur, like my parents.
So I went into the
business wanting
to be fair to
everybody who came in.
I wasn't just selling
white power music.
I was selling ska, and
rockabilly, and punk.
And I told myself I was
going to bite my tongue
and serve everybody
fairly because I wanted
to be a good businessman while
I was still selling white power
music from behind the counter.
One thing that
happened to me was
that people who I had
secluded myself from,
minorities and people
of other religions,
they started to
come into the store,
and they started to poke at me.
The knew I was
selling this music,
and they started to
ask questions about it.
And because we were
bonding over music,
I started to become
friends with these people
for the first time.
And I started to understand
through our conversations
was that the one thing
that we had in common
was that I felt the same pain
as the Jewish person did, that I
loved my wife and
my kids the same way
that the same sex
couple loved each other.
And I couldn't justify what
I was believing anymore.
I couldn't reconcile my hate
with this new-found love
and empathy that I
was starting to feel.
It wasn't until I had
started to humanize people
with empathy that it
started to break my shell.
So I think that empathy is
something that's lacking.
We were just in New
York this past weekend.
And we went to the 9/11
Memorial, which is incredible.
And it dawned on me that
the last time out country
was really united, and
that all races got along
with each other,
and all religions--
it didn't matter what religion
you were on September 11th.
And it's a real
tragedy to me to think
that the only time that
we can love each other
is when something
tragic happens.
And we had empathy
for each other.
And we put ourselves
in each other's shoes.
And we felt each other's
pain, and we came together
as a country.
And I think that that
empathy, if we can find a way
to get that back
in our daily lives,
without the tragedy
happening, we
can finally begin to
understand and not
be afraid of people that
are different than us,
and find a way to come together,
and hopefully make life better
for everybody.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
I'm all [INAUDIBLE].
Does anyone have any questions?
Please go to the mic.
We're doing some
recording today.
Thank you.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: And
all the hands go down.
AUDIENCE: So how--
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: Is it on?
It's not on.
AUDIENCE: I don't know
how to turn it on.
That button right there?
That button right there.
So how easy was it for
you to leave the movement?
It doesn't feel like it's
a membership you just
stop paying on, right?
It couldn't have been just one
day I'm out and I walk away.
Can you talk a little bit
about what that experience was?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
Absolutely.
And it's something
that I've shared
with other people who've left.
It's not an easy
process to leave.
One thing, throughout my
seven years of being involved,
I always had these moments
of clarity, I call them.
And they always happened
at really bad times
when I was involved in a fight.
And I would see somebody's
eyes open up the moment
before they passed out.
And it connected me to
them for just a moment.
And then I would squash it away.
But for seven years, I always
had these moments of clarity.
And I credit my life before
that, my parents and my family
not raising me that way.
But it was a really
hard process to leave.
And here's why.
So for seven years, I'd built
my whole social structure
within this movement.
All my friends were people
who were in the movement.
I didn't associate
with anybody who
wasn't a part of the movement.
So when I decided to leave, I
pulled the white power music
from my record store.
And because it was 75% of my
sales, the business tanked.
So I lost my job and
I closed the store.
My wife at the time
and my children,
who were just three and one,
left me because I was a part
of the movement
and they weren't.
I had always kind of been
that buffer between them.
I had alienated myself from
my parents and my family,
so I didn't really have
a relationship with them.
And I lost my whole
social structure.
Every friend that I
had during every one
of my formative
years, from 14 to 22,
was a part of this movement.
So I think it was
hard because I was
faced with losing everything.
It wasn't one thing
that got me out.
It was series of events.
It was my kids being
born, and their innocence,
and me not being able
reconcile my life with the love
that I had for them.
But it took me awhile to
pull the trigger and leave.
And closing the store,
getting divorced,
retreating into my
depression all helped me.
I was a leader of this group,
but I was selfish leader,
meaning that I didn't really
have an heir-apparent that I
had been grooming.
So when I left, when I
decided I'm out, I'm done,
the group kind of
imploded, luckily for me.
Because had it not
imploded, I don't know
that I'd be here right now.
So it's a tough process, but
I was surrounded by love,
even after, from my parents.
That helped me out.
That was major.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
for being here.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So we can you
talk a little bit about what
this movement did to your
relationship with your family
as you went through it,
and then how it has changed
or how you think about
it with your relationship
now with your kids and Britton?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: My
relationship with my parents
was really strained, obviously,
for those seven years.
Because they spent every moment
trying to get me out, bail me
out of jail, talk
me out of whatever
I was going to do that
day that maybe was not
going to be good for me.
So it put a lot of
pressure on them.
But it also helped me have
a really great relationship
with them now.
They're still annoying
parents but in a good way.
So I was able to rebuild
that relationship with them.
My kids saved my life.
If it hadn't been for my kids
being born when they did,
when I was 19 to 21 I don't
know that I would have changed.
Or it may have
taken a lot longer.
And as matter of fact, my
kids were the first people
to read my book when I finished
my first draft seven years ago.
And it was important for
me to share it with them.
I had talked to them about
what I'd been through,
but it was important for me
to get their feedback on it
because I wanted them
to see who I had been
and how I'd changed in
a more positive way.
I'm also really lucky,
knock on fake wood,
that my kids are nowhere
near as bad as I was.
They're really good kids.
When I'd met Britton, we'd
both been working for IBM
at the time.
I think it was 2001?
Maybe?
And she'd been
working in Dallas.
I was here in Chicago,
and I was part
of a team that was feeding
sales opportunities
to the inside sales team,
and Britton was working
for inside sales at IBM.
And we'd started
dating long distance.
And the first thing
that she did--
and I don't want to
say she googled it,
because I don't even think
that Google was around.
She Altavistaed it.
She found me online.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
Google was around.
I'm pretty sure it was Google.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
Were you using Google?
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: Yeah.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
She googled my name
and found something
that I'd written
that had shown up online.
And before we started
getting serious,
she confronted me with it.
And I'm glad she did
because that was really
one of the first
opportunities that I
had to talk publicly to
another person about what
I'd been through.
And it started this
ball rolling of me
talking more publicly about it.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
I didn't think
it was as serious as it was.
When I found it, it
was just a little piece
on a bulletin board.
And it sounded kind of militant,
but I was just like, oh,
whatever.
I was so white bread.
And so I just instant
messaged him like,
hey, are you as militant
as you used to be?
And just very flippant.
And he said, why?
And I said, oh, I just
saw this thing online.
And he's like, what?
And wanted me to
send him the link.
I think Christian was
incredibly fortunate
that he was involved
in the movement
before the digital age.
Because there really isn't
a digital record of what
was going on at that time.
Today would be insane.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: It's a
lot less forgiving, I think,
with that record.
So the thing that
she had found online
was something I'd written years
before that had been archived
and somebody had put it online.
And I had been out of the
movement for seven years
already at that point
when she found it.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
And I grilled him.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
But she grilled me.
And I'm glad she did, because it
started the ball rolling on me
talking about it publicly.
And then we met and here we are.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: Yes.
I got a husband and a job
out of the whole deal.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I also want
to say thanks for coming
and thanks for making
your story public.
I think it's really important
to get it out there.
I was wondering.
I forgot what the name of the
leader, the one who pulled up
in the car in the alley,
what his name was, but i
was wondering what
his trajectory was.
And post-movement, did you ever
cross paths with him again?
What happened to him?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
So what allowed
me to step into a leadership
role when I was 16 years ago
was that this
individual had gone
to prison for some violence that
he had committed in Chicago.
And he and a bunch of the
skinheads, they were all older,
and had gotten
into some trouble,
and had gone to prison.
And I was suddenly left
with this void where
I was one of the only people
left, me and the younger kids
who I had recruited.
So they had started to
look at me as the leader.
Clark had gone to
prison for seven years,
had some mental issues.
He and I had been
writing to each other,
and I recognized
pretty quickly that he
had some mental problems.
He's a brilliant guy, kind of
along the lines of a Charles
Manson-- very
charismatic, super smart
but in a very twisted way.
And I saw him one more time
in 1996 or '97 after he'd
gotten out of prison.
He had shown up
at one of the punk
rock shows that I had with
this non-political band
that I was playing in.
And I haven't seen him since.
I don't know where he is.
I've heard rumors.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
Not for lack of tyring.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
Yeah, I've tried.
I mean, researching,
fact checking just
for myself and my book.
I can't find anything.
I mean, part of it is because
he existed before the internet.
But I can't-- I don't know.
I think he's still alive.
I think he's still in Chicago.
I hope he's not damaging
anybody anymore.
I suspect he is,
but I don't know.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi, I have
two questions, actually.
Number one, I'm just
curious if you're
familiar with the film
"American History X"
and if you had any perspective
on how realistic that was.
Obviously, it was
Hollywood, but I just
would love to get your
perspective on it.
Number two, just a
personal question,
how would I recognize one of
these people on the street
if they're not a skinhead?
Just curious.
Also what neighborhoods
they may hang out in.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: I'll
start with your second question.
I don't know how you
will recognize them
because they do a really
good job of blending in.
A lot of folks went to
more mainstream, far
right organizations
like the Tea Party.
Not that all tea
partiers are bad,
if there's anybody in the room.
But it's hard.
It's really hard
spot them, which
is why we do a lot of
work with law enforcement
to help them understand the
mindset and the buzzwords
that they use.
I think it's a lot less active
in Chicago than it used to be,
but I don't know that for sure.
Your first question,
what was the film?
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
"American History X."
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
"American History X,
so "American History X" was
based on several people.
It's a composite
of several people.
I tend to believe
that it's partly
based on me and some
folks that I know.
Though I can't confirm that,
when you read the book,
you'll find that there
are a lot of similarities.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
[INAUDIBLE] in Life After Hate
with you is another person.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Yeah,
some people that I know,
it could have been
based on them.
I don't know.
As to how realistic it is,
it was pretty realistic.
I'd have to say that, for
a Hollywood production,
it was pretty accurate.
There's a lot of violence.
Music plays a central part
like it did in the movie.
There's always that
charismatic older person
who is recruiting and
holding these meetings.
They're messed up people
that drink a lot, and do
a lot of drugs, and cause a
lot of violence, sometimes
to each other.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, can I
ask one other question?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Could you
tell us, Christian,
what is a day in a
life of a skinhead.
What does it look like?
What are they thinking?
What are they doing?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
For me, you wake up,
you're probably unemployed or
working a pretty menial job.
There is a working class
ethic, although they rarely
stick to it.
They kind of pride themselves
on this middle class,
working class ethic.
But they drink a lot.
They do drugs, even
though they proclaim
that they don't because
they're supposed
to be these supreme beings.
But it's a lot of violence.
I mean, you're constantly
fighting with somebody
or watching your back.
Because all you do is you're
trying to recruit people.
You're preaching violence.
And they spin it.
So one thing that skinheads
are really good at,
or just racists in
general, is they
say it's about white pride.
We're just proud of who we are.
And when people
attack who we are,
that's when we get violent.
Well, it's bullshit.
Because behind the
scenes and internally,
it really is about supremacy.
It is about power.
It really is about
marginalizing and alienating
other people that
aren't like you.
So while they have
this outward marketing
face where it's all European
heritage, and pride, and--
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: Purity.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: It's not.
It really is about violence,
about hate, and prejudice.
And it's a pretty bad lifestyle.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: What I
found the most interesting
is that it was just a lot of
marketing genius at the time.
There was just tons
and tons of promotion.
AUDIENCE: I just also
wanted to say thank you
for bringing out the story.
I think it's important
for other kids who might
consider this as an option.
They know there's
a story out there
that's a counter-story, a
counter-narrative to what they
hear.
I mean, it makes my
heart race hearing all
of this-- just confrontations.
And when this topic comes
up, its just so dangerous.
And you're always
thinking you've
got to watch your back
or somebody's going
to confront something.
Even here sitting here talking
with someone as friendly
as you.
So I can only
imagine how much it
is for you to have to face
all this and this history.
So thank you very
much for sharing that.
I guess my question makes sense.
Something that you said
about taking responsibility
or scapegoating, even
just last week there's
somebody or some group posting
signs along the Lake Shore bike
trail with caricatures
of homeless people
and usual with
blackface kind of stuff.
Etcetera, right?
But the message
they're sending isn't
too different than from
what we tend to hear just
in normal mainstream talk-- just
stereotypes where we scapegoat.
Homeless people don't
want to get a job,
or women don't want to do
something smart and scientific,
or whatever?
Jews are controlling the
media and everything else
like you said.
Or Latinos are just gangbangers.
So I just wonder how
much the stereotypes that
permeate in mainstream
society envelope or provide
cover for what you said the
skinheads do, which is blend in
and operate that way.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, any
time that would happen,
that was a spark where
we threw gasoline on it.
And that's how we recruited.
So anytime we would hear
somebody say something pretty
normal, like what you're
talking about-- not normal,
but that's pervasive in society
today-- we would cozy up
to them and say, ah-hah.
Yes, you're right.
And start to put the
gasoline on that fire
and eventually recruit
them in over time.
And unfortunately,
those stereotypes
are flourishing in the
movement and in society.
And as we all know, most
times it's not true.
So we got to be very,
very good at using
those stereotypes
to recruit people
and pull them in further.
And all we can do
is be ourselves
and prove that those
stereotypes don't exist.
AUDIENCE: Hi, is this on?
I always want to say
thank you for coming.
It's such an engrossing story.
I'm from New York, and I've seen
a lot of local politics going
very right wing.
And it's very frightening.
And they ride on a ticket
of nationalism, immigration,
jobs-- that kind of thing.
So do you see that
populist movement, A,
growing-- I don't know.
I'm not too familiar
with American politics--
on a local level,
but also do you see
the membership of these
skinhead gangs growing?
Or is this declining right now?
What do you think?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
Well, I can you
tell that when President
Obama was elected that law
enforcement and
groups like the ADL
and the Southern Poverty Law
Center saw massive spikes
in enrollment in hate groups.
I do think it's happening here.
I think that our politics are
such that it's always divided.
There's always two opposing
sides to everything
and never a whole lot of
meeting in the middle.
And I have experienced
what you're
talking about in
Europe where they
play on nationalist tendencies.
And it works, unfortunately.
And I think it's
starting to work here.
I think we're seeing
a lot of homegrown,
far right nationalist
movements, Sovereign Citizen
groups, militia groups,
extreme constitutionalists.
They're doing some of the
same things in this country.
And the environment
is ripe for that now.
At least it has been
over the last decade
where unemployment
maybe has been higher.
And certainly when
there's an instance
of any kind of
foreign terrorism,
you can bet that
far right groups
are going to jump
on that and use
that to incite other people.
AUDIENCE: Here in our country,
I feel like a lot of our laws
protect white
supremacy in regards
to assembly and
free speech, whereas
in our European
counterparts, a lot of that
is actually illegal to assemble
or to have hate speech.
What are your thoughts on how
our country protects, loosely,
the ability to do that?
And do you think laws
should be changed?
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: I
believe in free speech.
And I think while our country
may protect hate speech
and assembly by hate
groups, in theory,
it also protects
everybody else and allows
them to have those freedoms.
I know in countries
like Germany,
the use of the swastika or
even saluting is illegal.
You can go to jail for that.
I don't know that the government
or law enforcement making
rules for us not to
say things or do things
is the right answer.
I think we as people just need
to do a better job of treating
other people with respect
and as human beings
to eliminate that
problem and still keep
the freedoms that we have.
That's a tough question.
Would I love to silence them?
Absolutely.
Do I think it's the
right thing to do?
I'm not so sure.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: All right.
Lynne's the last question.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Hi, Christian.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I find it
fascinating that I
know that your boys are in their
early teens if not early 20s,
and seven years ago would
put them right at that ripe
age of influence.
And I don't know if that
was by choice that you
put this narrative
in their hands,
but I'm wondering what
kind of active dialogue
that you have with them?
And I'm sure there are parents
and folks in this room who
speak on a regular
basis about beliefs,
and I think active
dialogue is so important.
So I want to know what
you think and what
you have and your behaviors with
them and the people around you.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
It was a decision
to start writing the book at
that because of their age.
It also kind of wasn't.
But I think an active dialogue,
exactly what you said,
is important.
Just talk to your--
more Importantly
than talking your kids,
listen to your kids.
Because while I'm not that
far in age from my kids--
I'm 41 and my kids
are 22 and 20,
and I'd like to think that I
still remember what it's like
to be that age, I don't.
I don't remember.
And they're going through it.
So listen to them.
Because they'll tell you clues.
If there's something
lacking in their life,
they'll give you the clues.
If there's something going
wrong, if you're looking,
you can spot it.
So when the kids
were old enough,
I told then about my past.
I told them what
I'd gone through.
But I didn't dwell
on that too much
as I did on focusing on the
counter-narrative of treat
people with respect if
you want respect back.
Treat people fairly if you
want to live a fair life.
And no matter what
you're going through,
somebody else is always
going through something worse
than you.
So just be kind and put
yourself in people's shoes
before and after you do
anything to understand what
it might make them feel like.
So that was always a constant
conversation that we had.
And they're teenagers,
so of course
they goof up and do things
that they're not supposed to.
But luckily, between Britton
and me and their mom,
I think we've done an OK job.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
Nobody was in jail.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Not
like I was [INAUDIBLE].
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: Right.
This is good.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
And for the record,
I only went to prison just
overnight, local jail.
Fights, [INAUDIBLE].
BRITTON PICCIOLINI: Thanks,
everyone, for coming.
So "Romantic Violence" is
actually out officially today.
So hopefully all
of youi got a copy.
Please recommend it
to anyone that you
think might be
interested in the story.
Thank you to Christian
Picciolini for joining us.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI:
Thank you for joining too.
If anybody didn't get a copy,
I brought a copy from home.
So you're welcome, if you
didn't get a copy and want one,
to take this copy.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
BRITTON PICCIOLINI:
Thanks, everyone.
CHRISTIAN PICCIOLINI: Thank you.